the 2019 all-star is back sandy
alcantara is arriving in the big leagues
now this one driven deep into right
field that's got good carry and will get
out of here home run for joey wendell to
start the day
ray's lead one nothing middle in and
there's the change up at 90. he is
pulling for power that ball left at the
belt he was not fooled at all by the
change of speed so one on one in one out
and here is yoshi and the one two pitch
and yoshi lifts this one in the air to
right center field back at it as
princeton he's still going back at the
wall it's gone
yoshi sutsugo with a two-run home run
and the rays have put a crooked number
up on the board it's three-nothing here
in the first so yoshi got a pitch middle
end and he did not miss it well it's
been a straightforward line of progress
for blake snell
start after start after start moving in
the right direction
and now throw over to first they're
gonna get birdie blake picks it up goes
right over nice exchange
get the tag
and the fastball tied him up in
95 got him on the strikeout a three-run
lead for blake snell
that's a cut in the mess anderson out on
strikes
so yandy diaz is about to step in
and here he chops one on a high hop to
third base and he's got it goes to
second one back to first they get two
five four three the three two two on
delivery and that's in there for strike
three called caught him looking at a
change up up in the zone
ray's off to a three-nothing lead bottom
of the third coming
and look at that breaking ball comes
back to get him you know what and we've
seen that i don't remember blake you
know his first few starts seeing that
many curve balls to the left-handed
hitters
with one out under rin fro
a little chop toward the middle
this will be played by vr in a wide
throw to first everybody's going to be
safe
here's kevin kiermeier
and that pitch it's a fastball too high
the bases are loaded on that walk so the
rays have loaded him up here for kevin
smith and first pitch to him for
alcantara out of the set swinging a
bounty ball past third fair ball
anderson steps on the bag there's an out
throw to first it's a wild throw and
goes all the way down the right field
line and now the throw gets away and
it's too late and then the throw to the
plate is late once again
and two more runs score for the raise
but the marlins in this inning have had
some serious issues with the throws i
mean nowhere near the targets and you
don't care meyer he likes to run so he's
just going to keep going corey differs
in the plate he bounced to first his
first time up
on 2-1 dickerson high fly ball right
field going back renfro way back on the
track at the wall goodbye corey
dickerson a home run to end the
scoreless inning drought at 22. corey's
a good curveball hitter he's going to
get another one from snell and just
unload
the game
pitch lifted
into right center and past the diving
brenson joy's on his way to second he
stops with a double to g-man choi with
his second hit so it's william thomas
who will greet him with the bases full
on the infield coming in
that's one sky deep to left dickerson
will go to the wall that's got a chance
to go
elite by dickerson and that ball is gone
boy dickerson
tried to time it and came close to
catching it a grand slam for willy adams
on a 2-0 pitch and the raids do indeed
break this one open
oh he felt it in the webbing yep tried
to bring it back
jeremiah batting with the runner in
second
now a drive off the bat of kiermeier
that ball is well tagged and that's
going to get out of here well over that
387 marker a two run home run
for keermeyer his first of the year and
the rays continue
to build
a gigantic inning here well it's a seven
run inning with nobody out lewis brenton
who applied to center his first time up
brinson
hits this one well to left center field
and that is
gone a home run for lewis brinson
it has been quite some time for sweet
lou
he has been swinging the bat better he
has been getting better results kind of
using the whole field
front foot down beautiful swing
and now cooper sends one deep into left
center field oh that might be over
autonation alley how about that for
garrett cooper
that is getting hold of a fastball a
first pitch center cut fastball just
above the knees a no doubter
well they are loaded with nobody out for
garrett cooper
and that is hit hard fair down the line
this will go to the corner one rental
score birdies coming around to score
dickerson gets the green light and the
marlins get closer here in the seventh
on a bases clearing double for garrett
cooper lefty against the lefty
on 2-2 joyce lines one to right gonna
get down for a base hit
that's gonna score cooper it's gonna
kick away from renfro in right field
joyce is headed for second base and it's
12 to seven
goes after this one and lofts it deep
into right center is going to be caught
by renfro and the rays win this one a
one two three nine for sheriff and the
rays when they're fifth in a row they
sweep
the miami marlins in miami